thrilled to be able to call him a friend
uh i will watch anything that he is in
movies or tv because he is fantastic in
all of them
and this looks just fantastic on netflix
available for streaming today
thunder force directed by ben falcone
who is the uh husband of melissa
mccarthy who's in this movie with
octavius spencer and jason bateman and
this man
bobby cannavale how are you bobby yeah
what an intro
that's what i do would you record my
outgoing message maybe upset again
for me yes that's like nice rich
nice to hear your voice do you want me
to do that right now i could record it
and send you the uh
the voice note would you want me to do
that i could do that yeah i would like
that
okay here it is um don't mention you
know
okay don't mention don't mention that
you know who eps oh and it's it's all
good here we go
hey you reach bobby's phone he's too
busy to talk to you
so leave a message he might call you
back he might not what do you care
how's that is it too aggressive is it
too aggressive i love it i love it is it
to it yeah is it
it's pretty good it might be too
aggressive what if a loved one calls you
i don't know
but it's just i don't know i'm yeah i'm
feeling my oats bobby
i'm feeling my oats today how are you
i'm good power i'm i'm i'm doing well
thank you
all right everybody's good let's dive
right into it let's dive right into it
um sam darnold is gone you you you
you're good with that
what yeah i mean you know yeah sure why
not um
by the way that should be a drop that's
a drop
yeah sure why not that's the point at
this point you know
you know the other day i got into a
heated discussion about the jets and
then like
and then like i just got tired of
talking about it so i'd like i finished
the whole i just shut the conversation
down
by saying from my heart this team has
never done anything for me
and like i feel like i feel like that's
like a mantra for jets fans pre-1969
right which would make it you know uh
make us all pretty old but
it's true they haven't done anything for
me yet but sure get rid of sam darnold
too
you know well i think you're giving
voice to what i was saying
and and so what i was saying is here we
are as jet fans again
we're we're going to buy in right we're
going to buy in zach wilson's the guy
sam's not you know exactly what else are
we going to do
and at some point we are gonna have
dropping out of the sky as kansas city
had and seattle had and new england had
just to name three
the draft gods are gonna drop the answer
finally out of the sky and it's gonna be
the
perfect marriage of coach and
quarterback and 15 20 years later we'll
be just you know talking about all those
canyon of hero moments
and what else we what else we got to do
except keep believing you know
that's it we got to keep believing
because you know what happens the moment
you stop like they're going to win
so i cannot that i can't let that happen
so i mean look it's good right we got
the number two pick
i kind of i kind of assumed we were
going to do that i kind of assumed we
were going to let him go and
you know the talent in this draft at
that high it's too good isn't it i mean
yes i agree with you the talent you know
if we have a chance at getting a better
quarterback at that position than the
one we have now then logic
would dictate that that's what we do but
it is the chats
i don't know why they dropped a photo of
chad pennington and i was like what are
you doing to me
what what's happening here what what am
i supposed to do with this information
is this some kind of weird hint are we
taking the martial quarterback this year
at number two wouldn't that be something
can you redraft chad pennington is that
what the chats are googling right now
can you redraft somebody that's what
they're putting into a google search
right now
at a computer somewhere in new jersey
but here's the thing too is
it that's pretty amazing also and you're
perfect to talk to about this bobby
knowing the new york new jersey
metropolitan area as well as you do
it's yes with zach wilson being the guy
what's the grand total number of jet
fans and i really want a number from you
grand total number of jet fans who have
actually watched a byu football game
from start to finish
what is it you mean since robbie bosco
i
top five byu quarterbacks just so i
could drop that robbie bob
joke on you
no i'm joking i mean jim mcmahon of
course steve young writes great history
sure
but uh that's two guys ty detmer had a
long career look at you
you're on a roll no you're on i remember
those guys and now zack wilson um you
got five
and zach wilson hey look the guy did
complete 75
of his passes that's pretty good he's a
big strong guy
i think we have to i think we have to
draft another receiver right or at least
or at least uh you know uh uh just
another offensive
playmaker you know whether it be a
running back or a receiver i'd like to
see them get another receiver
i don't know about corey davis i'm not
sure about that
um but you know who knows i think that
that picket number 23 is going to be
interesting
yes what do you think we're going to do
exactly i don't know it's going to be
one of those best player available type
guys and i don't know
you know who might be there um i do like
cory i mean a linebacker does that mean
you know a guy like
waddle or a tight end no i i think
waddle will be long gone
by 23. oh i think for sure but you know
i i don't know the answer to that and
that is part of the the
the the excitement here is that i do
believe
the general manager that they have and
joe douglas i
and i i i say this with all you know uh
nervousness because this is who we are
as jet fans i think he's got this
i think he's go i think he knows what
he's doing i like the hired coach
i like the fact that you know that they
that they did get something for darnold
that
uh that they can use down the road um
i like it i think they got something i
think they got something cooking here
bobby you use the word excitement
do we have the same definition of what
that word means
do you mean excitement or do you mean
like extreme dread
because i'm excited too but it's like
parts of my body the wrong parts of my
body are getting excited about what
we're going to
do we're going to mess this up but truly
i'm with you and i want to believe too
dude i really do want to believe you
know i feel good about our coach coming
in
that looks great right that's all
anybody says that guy looks crazy great
yeah i know but he's not going to throw
he's not slinging the ball he's not you
know
i i i i i i'm optimistic but i'm
cautiously optimistic
right that he looks good and he's in
shape let's just say that we never heard
that about coattite you know what i mean
like said lisa
no we never heard that about co-type
code type though kota must be thrilled
about adam gates right i mean like
he's stoked he's stoked to be about adam
gates
i mean yeah he and bruce castle are
popping champagne corks right now
oh it's like like the 70 dolla the 72
dolphins right now they're popping
champagne
oh my god it's really a shame
it's a shame i mean there is something
charming about being a fan of the jets
right i mean there's something kind of
cute about it
you know sure so i'll stick with that
and
uh and and you know hey crazier things
have happened before
and you know this guy could bring a good
culture to the team and you know that
they haven't had quite
have they go it just hasn't gelled like
the vibe has never quite felt right
i thought it was feeling right when todd
bowles was the coach and i went to their
training camp i went for a couple of
days and
nobody seemed to be super into him and
still we couldn't win
i know you never know man but i i like i
said well we'll
in byu quarterbacks we trust i mean
that's pretty much it and
now that they traded sam darnold they
got to put zach wilson
in uh bubble wrap he's not allowed to go
out we should all
sort of put money together for to give
him a sort of a door dash or
or postmates or whatever it is where he
can just order out he can't
pass the age when you stop getting mono
you're not gonna get mono and chicken
pox i'm pretty sure
you know what that's a great question i
don't know the answer but uh we should
we gotta ask zach if he's up on his
mumps measles and rubella shots right we
gotta
you got your mmr right zach you got that
you know what i mean like that that's
what that's basically between now
and april 29th he can't go out he should
stay home and uh he should stay home and
watch thunder force
right right bobby what do you think
about that exactly what he should do he
should stay home and watch thunder force
which is dropping today as you know on
netflix yes indeed
this looks exciting this looks fantastic
bobby this looks hilarious
it's very fun you know i'm a big huge
fan of melissa's
mccarthy's and we've worked together a
bunch of times and
you know bateman is bateman in crab
claws playing it straight
like he doesn't have crab claws is one
of the funniest things you'll see
all year guy guy knows what he's doing
you know what i mean
um because he doesn't have any powers
you know he's just a guy who crap
clothes
that's what's funny so what else is he
going to do that's what's the biggest
thing
why do you think your guy became a bad
guy became a mystery and he's like
let me tell him what do you mean what
else i'm gonna do i can't even open a
car door
and and you play you play a villain in
this one bobby so you're back
you're back to the the villain role here
uh
in this one you play the king a power
hungry billionaire
assembling a group of miscreants here
that's what you got going on
i'm looking at that exactly yeah i'm
like the i'm like the lex luthor
of the um of the bad guys in this one
and so that's my crew
involved and my crew includes uh uh palm
who plays laser and uh
and bateman and uh and we're just a
bunch of uh
sort of weird uh weird bad guys with
strange powers like my powers are my
eyes light up red i asked that's how
come the director i said
hey what happens with my what what what
what does that do with my lights
my turn ready goes you know i think they
just burn a little bit and i go no i
mean what are they what's the power
and he's like no no i think they just
burn a little bit your eyes i think
oh i said oh there's no benefit he goes
no it just looks cool
so so these guys don't really have
incredible superpowers except that i can
plug people to death that's my other big
talent so so i decided you know me i
like to go deep
yes um uh i just thought
well i'm gonna approach it from there
this guy hasn't you know he can't he
can't ever find
true love because uh as soon as he gets
critical of anybody it's over you know
they're dead
he also has a problem that he's got very
thin skin
and so uh he keeps on wasting his
henchmen you know he gets insulted by
them or he takes a slight from them and
he
uh and he you know he kills them so
it sounds very gyproceti-like without i
guess the s m and bondage
uh bobby you know yeah it is very
similar to that character they're just
you know pin skin egotistical uh
politicians
really hard to find those out there well
done uh and so uh ewan bateman was there
a dodger
yankee rivalry on the set in any way
shape or form i don't know when you shot
this was this
oh no i guess we couldn't we didn't talk
about it
because he didn't bring it up and i wish
i could say
you know uh ben falcone militant husband
the writer director of the
phillies fan but he's one of those
phillies fans who also likes the yankees
i love those guys you know
yankees are their second favorite team
you're like
you just feel sorry for him a little bit
you know yeah you should kind of upgrade
that one right there
yeah what kind of yeah yeah yeah so
i don't did you see you're excited about
the yankees hey yeah well hey you know
what i i
i i have no idea gary cole is like
sitting in a rocking chair thank god
um you know and judge i don't know what
the hell's going on with his health he's
already out of the lineup again
today um i don't know what's going on
with that one did you see what happened
with the
the mets at citi field yesterday did you
see that one
no what did you see with that one
michael conforto leaned into a pitch
uh oh yeah yeah yeah that's a strike
that's yes it certainly is
supposed there was a strike on his elbow
that he leaned in across the plate yeah
you know yeah yeah yeah that bit yeah
yeah
yeah that was uh that's a very lucky win
for them everybody but everybody i
watched those interviews
everybody seemed to be saying yeah sorry
uh i don't know you know like everybody
seemed to know
what was going on there of course
everybody except the home plate umpire
unfortunately for for the and i just it
just
i don't know it just hurts me to my core
bobby
to see don mattingly upset about
anything him robbed about from any
i just can't it's just it's just i still
have that soft spot
for number 23 in your program he's still
number one in my heart
you know and i feel like don he's just
getting screwed man
it just hurt me to see that yeah you
know
yeah and you know you know i it's so
funny like i i know you love manning me
like i do so i follow everything that
happens with him too
and i'm not a marlins fan but god darn
it like why did jeter have to go there
why didn't mattingly vote like we should
be
fans of that team sort of uh
it's tough because i just root for the
guy and uh yeah you want to see him
uh you just want to see things go well
for him you know i hope he ends up
coming back and managing
you know like that's the weird thing
about sort of kind of rooting for the uh
for the marlins is
you know what what's good for mattingly
is good for us as yankees fans because
then he can come back and
you know skip this team you know
eventually well you know everybody
accused jeter of handing us
giancarlo stanton anyway um and uh that
kind of worked
looked like it worked out for the
marlins you know what i mean yeah
so you never know but um ah i hope
then i hope sentence gets gets with the
program i mean that was a
he crushed it the other night so he did
hit one like 500 feet
that didn't happen all right well bobby
i love chatting with you great catching
up with you thunderforce is available
for streaming today
on netflix um what else is going on
anything else i need to know you're
already working on the next thing you
got something else going on already
imagine or what are you doing you're
just chilling out for the moment yeah no
i'm not doing anything i'm just
you know i'm just waiting for the
football season playing with the guys
uh you know this this year's taught me
anything it's uh
is that those two guys are pretty good
value so uh i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna stick with them for a few more
months before i go back to work i don't
think i'm gonna go back to work until
like september
all right fantastic in the meantime just
uh just scrub all that
all 22 uh tape of byu football tell me
what you think
of zach wilson and then we'll we'll
we'll put our heads together before the
draft
how does that look you know what i
forgot the guy's name i said in the
beginning of the interview
i've even forgotten it because robbie
bosco sorry
that's an incredible pull man i mean
seriously honestly you ask any new
yorker on the street that's a die-hard
jet fan
tell me something about about byu or
utah
and they might talk about the osmonds
you know what i mean like they don't
know
yeah you know what else is surprising
about them is that they've only got that
one national championship of all those
great quarterbacks only robbie bosco
got them the national championship i
hope they're doing the weird thing
i think they're doing the right thing i
really believe they're doing the right
thing and then
um you know he looks good he looks good
and maybe
you know again maybe this guy sally and
our office reporter maybe these young
guys maybe
you know there is something about we see
it as a trend right in all the sports
right he's got these coaches and
the staffs are getting younger and
younger uh maybe there's something to
that
and uh and i sure hope so because i'll
tell you what look what sean mcveigh
look what mcvay did
his first year in in los angeles right
it can happen
don't no doubt about it you know with a
with a quarterback who's he doesn't have
a lot of experience right here obviously
you take care of yourself bobby let's
chat soon you're cool you're the best
brother
okay that's bobby cannavale at bobby
underscore carnivale on
instagram he tapped out on twitter a
couple years ago
netflix's thunderforce the two-time emmy
award-winning actor
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here